[Music]
thank you
since opening in 1985 Les Miserables has
become something of an institution here
in the West End not only is it the
world's longest running musical it's
been seen by more than 60 million people
in 42 countries and in 21 different
languages if somebody told you that way
back when would you have believed it
would have laughed
anyway you say you knew you were working
on something good though yes I
absolutely I loved it but there was no
way that anyone can imagine something
running this long it's crazy isn't it
and it's probably gonna launch it
probably outlive me
I think it's one of the great stories of
the Triumph of the human spirit and it's
got
um because it's got so many characters
it's got so many ways in you know you've
got the story of Valjean which
involves the discovery of virtue and the
discovery of Faith the discovery of love
for a child and and what it's like to be
a parent what it's like what it's like
to let a child go out into the world
then you've got a kind of more Teenage
Love Triangle story the story of
unrequited love with eponine kids will
you know enjoyed gavrosh and little
Gazette stories uh and um any obsessive
policeman could enjoy
[Music]
Japan's crime was stealing a loaf of
bread
it was the beginning of a lifelong
confrontation Les Mis miraculously is
the longest running music in the world
and um
it's I mean I'm as surprised as anybody
you know I mean I you know I I always
thought it was a a very terrific musical
but I never had any thought that a show
of such serious note would actually run
as long but it seems to touch every
generation everywhere in the world I
mean Victor Hugo's story
um you know is about contemporary people
even though it's set in a period setting
and every country in the world seems to
react to it and of course
music
I just is those songs are absolutely
fantastic and they're Timeless and it
speaks to an audience of any age
let's not forget though that Victor Hugo
was already an International Celebrity
by the time he got to age 30. he was
known as the prince of poets and was uh
shall we say massive within the Romantic
Movement more importantly of course he
was what you would uh I suppose assume
today just a huge celebrity end of who
would have thought though that so many
years later his name would still be
synonymous really with the world of
musical theater not just really in his
home country or even indeed in Britain
but worldwide
take him off
Duel of Wills with the fnatic Police
Inspector Javert continue the hope of
Escape was his only reason for living oh
decision of the Military Tribunal that
five years be added to your sentence you
must have been asked many times but can
you in any way put your finger on what
it is that has made it the longest
running show ever well I personally
think it's the the story Victor Hugo's
Masterpiece Les Miserables he mustn't
cry
he must be very brave with all the power
and spectacle of those turbulent years
leading to the French Revolution it is a
story of incredible courage and
Relentless Pursuit growing up
an exciting Panorama that captures the
spirit of a rebellious generation it's
the most interesting Universal story and
it it touches everybody and
I remember watching some of the scenes
that I wasn't in way back before it went
on you know during rehearsals and I was
sobbing my heart out and then I had and
I thought oh my God it's my scene coming
up next I had to pull myself together
I mean this show um
well it makes men cry put it that way
it's a beautiful Story I mean whether
you're into musicals or not it's one of
the great stories Ever Told
foreign
Point really for Victor Hugo's
Masterpiece Les Miserables really
started way back in June 1832 he was sat
in a park relaxing heard a rather
strange noise at first found out that it
was gunfire which then led him into the
June Revolution which of course then
formed the basis of possibly his best
and most famous idea
you
today
another we will lay our hand our hand
sword hilt of God and Shout down with
the bore balls down with the monarchy it
was the first lesson I learned it
doesn't matter how good the songs are if
the book isn't
strong and that the songs don't grow out
of the book you don't have a good
musical
Victor's first full-length novel was one
that we know by a better title now but
when it first came out it was known as
Notre Dame de Paris which then in turn
became of course more famous as the
Hunchback of Notre Dame been remade so
many times most famously of course by
Hollywood in the late 30s with Charles
Laughton but that really did open many
doors for Victor and he became even more
celebrated if that were possible now
just to put this in sort of a bracket if
you like Paris and France in particular
were already in the grip of some rather
dramatic themselves they've been a
massive outbreak of Cholera with over 19
000 parisians dying now some people
thought that this was really set up by
the government as one of those mad
theories you know because they were
trying to poison off for want of a
better word some of the Lesser desirable
residents of Parisian Society the under
dogs and this of course then fascinated
Yugo himself giving him even more spark
to an already dramatic story
now not many people will know that
Victor Hugo wrote Les Miserables in his
long years of Exile in the Channel
Islands and to get inspiration for this
um he would write naked at his desk
every day shocking some people who would
actually turn up uh to take tea with him
and things like that I think what's
interesting to note as well he didn't
really Rush this particular Masterpiece
he went through many many different
rewrites and for a while it sat around
by himself you know he changed plot
decided to pick it up go back to it
again he was known as a perfectionist
and I think of course like anybody who'd
enjoyed Jude's success it would be like
today releasing a Bond movie you know
everybody's going to criticize
everybody's going to say whether they
like it or not and he was under immense
pressure to make sure what he came up
with next was of course an international
Smash and of course when it first came
out that wasn't necessarily the case
Victor Hugo's Les Miserables really was
the most anticipated publication in
years and New York Society was a gag
waiting to know how it would be done and
to give you just an Insight really as to
how even back then they were very clever
they decided to mount this massive PR
campaign and so they would drop in
little teasers rather like what they do
say with a Harry Potter movie in today's
decade so they just drop a little bit in
and then they came up with the first
sort of take the second take and by the
time of course the final volume was
released it was a momentum everybody
wanted to copy everybody needed to be
seen with a copy of their book it was
the coffee table equivalent of gold dust
if you like and once again of course he
was looking at a mega Smash Hit Cameron
McIntosh was sent a demo attack based on
Victor Hugo's novel Les Miserables two
French composers Claude Michelle
Schoenberg and Allen bublil worked
closely with him developing the score
we never go ahead with anything unless
all three of us absolutely agree
um on every step of the way I think that
whole dude
I cannot do it without the first part
because you can do it
it's like a a safety break but if if two
if two likes something and the others
doesn't it means that actually we
haven't got the right solution and we
then carry on until we find a third
solution when Victor Hugo passed away in
May 1885 he was considered a national
hero of a two million people maundered
his funeral but this is the interesting
thing the theme of course throughout Les
Miserables is all about social injustice
and he'd requested that he wanted a
pauper's funeral sadly though for him
that wish was not carried out and he
became if possible an even bigger
cultural literally and of course
celebrity icon when I first heard it was
called Les Miserables I thought so I
don't know if that name's gonna work and
um and so we called it the glums and um
now you know Les Miserables is the name
that everybody knows worldwide
and even if you don't speak French you
know the name since the publication of
Les Miserables there's been no less than
48 operatic versions but the version
really that we know and love today
actually started out way back in 1980 as
just a simple concept album can you not
actually get that with a different
slightly different Rhythm because that's
got that's got the Menace that you're
talking about I think a producer
shouldn't write for writers I don't
think director should do that the
writers and lyricists of the wonderful
concept album were allegedly inspired by
another British phenomenon that of
Lionel baths Oliver the record-breaking
musical apparently they were sat down
watching it in a theater and
particularly taking interest in The
Artful Dodger and as they were watching
Oliver unfold on stage they decided how
they could almost see Les Miserables
taking shape in their own musical Opera
themselves simply by just watching
Oliver now who would have thought that a
simple project like Lionel Bart's Oliver
which also had its own problems just
like Les Miserables would explode from
just an afternoon we are there to
complement that the writer's imagination
and to bring
bring that writing to its best fruition
what I'm very good at is saying this
bit's dull this song does not
sort of come to a proper Climax and I'm
I'm just fascinated about how uh how
right how the writing develops
um and how that you take a basically
good story and you make sure that that
the the graph of emotion throughout the
evening is hit exactly right three
months after the concept album had
topped the charts in France someone
decided to take the rather risky Venture
of taking it to the stage once again the
critics were less than nice about this
particular new musical but Word of Mouth
took off once again making the
three-month run a sellout of course by
this point other people were taking
notice not just in France but around the
world that's the thing that I always aim
for for my production so once the
audience settles down first thing you've
got to do is in the first five minutes
is to tell them the language of the
evening that you're going to use way
back in 1980 the first original concept
album of Les Mis was released it topped
the charts without really much promotion
and three months later they decided to
Stage the very first musical version
based on the concept album this just
broke box office records with over a
million plus people wanting to see the
production then of course this was
brought to the attention of who we know
now to be the Super producer none other
than our very own Cameron Macintosh but
it will take him quite some time before
he could turn it into the British
phenomenon that we know and love and
take it around the world but when he
first heard the concept album he thought
there could be something in it of course
he had no idea just that something would
make him very very rich indeed okay one
two three whoa
I knew from the beginning I wanted to do
the singing live and it was I was so
passionate about it I wasn't willing to
make the film unless I could do the
singing and this is because I I always
find singing to to play back to
prerequord however what it's done as an
artifice and it's worse it makes you
embarrassed at the best you have to just
forgive it and a lighter a comedic film
it's easy to it's easier to forgive but
I I wanted there to be no barrier
between the audience and the experience
of his emotions
foreign
in terms of how it was made it was a
truly British production the
internationalism was you know really in
the past was one of the best people in
the world who would do this
um that doesn't mean the British aren't
the best singers but you know I needed
to look a little further
personally interesting to take note of
is the fact that when this show launched
in October 1985 nobody really could have
seen just how big it was going to be and
you know the critics as I say loathed it
I'm a rather cruel in fact not really
just about the length of the musical you
know the fact that they were getting a
free ticket and the fact that you know
how to sit and endure it but they didn't
really understand even when it started
to take off and become a huge box office
phenomena they couldn't understand why
the public liked it the Posh papers said
that we had
trivialized I'm one of the greatest
works of Western literature the tabloids
agreed between themselves that we had
um perpetrated a gloomy doll
endless evening which wasn't what
musicals were about at all musicals
should be light and frothy and frivolous
evenings and sent everybody away happy
and humming the tunes it took two years
for Cameron McIntosh and his team to
make the English language version of
what we know as Les Miserables today but
in October 1985 it opened at the less
than glamorous location off West End in
the Barbican
although his father is Scottish
Macintosh himself was brought up in the
home counties his mother is Maltese and
his parents met in answer during the war
when he was young he was always standing
on chairs with a stick in his hand as if
he had a great Orchestra in front of him
and
I thought he was going to be a sort of
band Master band leader or something
like that then he started
with a puppet show
[Music]
I know a lot of people do puppet shows
but they don't normally Drive the family
entirely batty all year
the first thing he used to tell us if
you're late you won't come in
so let's say well
we don't come in you'll have no audience
he said never mind every show you must
be on time I just finished playing a
performance imaginary performance of
Saturdays
and the stage door keeper came to my
addressing room and said excuse me sir
I'm sorry to bother you but there's a
lady at the stage door with a little boy
and she says that he absolutely insists
upon seeing you so uh in UK Cameron and
was it your aunt that was with you I
think it was my aunt my mother and my
Kilt yes I remember all killed very well
and Julian instead of sort of patting me
on the head and giving me some candy
floss actually took me terribly
seriously and showed me backstage of how
them he mimed with Minnie the magic
piano from the pit and how the Flying
Saucer worked was attached to wires and
I just remember sitting on this stale
standing on this stage looking around
and thinking yes I'd like to do this
when I grow up my nickname at school was
Daryl F McIntosh after Darren zanek who
is having lots of successful films then
and again I used to start the first day
of the Autumn term preparing for the
Christmas review
if people books in advance they could
get the tickets for a shilling and if
they got them nearer the date they had
to pay two Shillings I was like a Hoover
I sucked up any information about the
theater
um I got magazines from America from and
every newspaper and article I could
about anything about the theater so I
was also walking encyclopedia at school
and drove everybody mad who were much
more interested in the football results
when he left school Cameron McIntosh
decided to try the stage management
course at the Central School of speech
and drama
but he left after only a year to get
proper backstage experience at the
theater Royal Drury line
in the mornings he also cleaned the
theater to earn extra money
I took great pride cleaning that theater
the dress Circle bar was my domain it's
the most very carefully polish all the
brass and wash the glass so it must be
rather nice for you to be back into a
related with Miss Saigon it's oh it's
it's like coming home I I've always had
that's the one dream I've had was to
have a show on a Drury Lane
he did a variety of jobs backstage
including a spell-up in the Flies
hauling scenery up and down
and as I undid the ropes they caught
around my hand and I was flown the
weight of this huge piece of scenery
took me right up to the grid and it
stopped literally six inches from the
grid I would have only because it was a
very tall piece of scenery that had
landed on the stage and they had to cut
me down
you know people think it's pretty easy
to be an emphasize believe me it ain't
It Ain't Easy at all choreographers and
directors always argue the book writer
tends to argue with the composer and
Lyricist and it's very important to have
a strong producer at the top because in
a sense he is the one who has to balance
all the elements and control all the
elements
I knew the moment I started to talk to
Cameron in detail that there was a man
after my own heart he had just the same
enthusiasm just the same care that it
must be glamorous and beautifully done
that you don't save Pennies on the
costumes or save Pennies on the on the
scene reels and you do it properly you
don't try and scrape into a smaller
Orchestra I'm not a great musician
though I can tell When the Music's right
or wrong
I can overlap into his area by sort of
prodding him here and there and thinking
don't we need something like that or is
that mood right or whatever in in his
scoring Cameron is really much more of
an old-fashioned producer in the sense
that he does have strong creative views
and sometimes the team who he works with
don't share them but he has a a a very
strong view on practically everything in
fact one of his qualities is that I mean
he could be two minutes into a song and
uh he'll come up and say I don't like
that one it doesn't work doesn't it Go
Cameron just wait a minute we just let's
get through the end and we'll work it
out well I can't help myself I mean I'm
one of these people that just says my
says what I feel even if it isn't right
I just have to get out of my system but
I've got to sort of I sort of like a
sort of terrible truffle Hound sort of
smelling
um spots in the show which aren't which
I don't think are right and I just keep
on and on and on until it just to shut
me up they'll go away at least about he
had one complete set of orchestrations
made
and then he decided that he didn't like
them it wasn't right for the show he got
rid of that orchestrator and hired
another orchestrator to then did two
more dummy runs of orchestrations I had
to scrap an entire concept album which
cost over 300 000 pounds
which went
down the Swanee but it was worth it in
the end have you ever seen a zebra and a
giraffe in the jungle I mean that they
wanted
but I have last year and I can tell you
to a certain extent uh now we live in a
world that's divided into two Stephen
Sondheim gets all the critical Acclaim
and the shows that Cameron McIntosh and
Andrew Lloyd Webber do are derided as
Taurus schlock and produces Reigns as as
kings of the theater coincide for the
amount of time that the Public's taste
also happens to be the producer's taste
and when that changes then no matter how
successful you are you you go out the
window this has happened to David
Merrick this has happened to Harold
fielding and which one day will happen
to Cameron McIntosh too one thing when I
started off I was given a book about
Cochrane well the showman looks on its
autobiography and one thing stuck early
on in my life it was his advice to
aspiring young producers he said never
put a show on for the audiences always
put it on for yourself and do it as best
as you can and then maybe an audience
will come and see it
and I think that's pretty good advice
it's not just a West End phenomenon that
continues to be a box office hit around
the globe a staggering 56 million people
have now seen Les Mis that's almost the
equivalent of every man woman and child
living in this country
Michael Ball sings with Leia Salonga but
this is not a scene from their hit shows
Phantom of the Opera or Miss Saigon it's
another hit both have Sean in separately
Lim is a Rob but everyone here has been
very jolly because it's Les miser's 10th
birthday and hundreds of the cast from
its Productions around the world are
giving a Gala concert on Sunday but
without props or costumes and new cast
members it can get confusing which way
to go off stage but everything should be
smoothed out by Sunday when thousands of
adoring fans descend on the Albert Hall
the Seal of making this successful was
the fact that it won best musical at the
Lawrence Olivier Awards in 1985. for
them that suddenly really had a bit of a
clout and suddenly people decided to
take notice it shot out of the Barbican
and into the West end where it's
basically remained for the last 25 years
and when you think about it you know it
just goes to show that even though you
know people would say oh no you know the
theme is not very good and it's not a
warm sort of topic of course it's not
Victor Hugo wanted to get social
injustice out there and that's what he
did but the songs are so memorable and
they've been recorded from everyone from
the likes of Dame Shirley Bassey right
through to some of our most celebrated
opera stars including of course Luciano
Pavarotti but I think what really
cemented it in the end was that the
public pushed this through
and as someone who attends many sort of
opening nights in theaters Les Mis fans
are nothing like I've ever met before
they're very loyal some people in fact
actually booked the same seat every
matinee and turn up week after week
after week they know the show backwards
they know everything about you know when
the lights should come on the scene
changes if somebody's feeling ill in the
cast they become like friends and one of
the connecting factors that I think
Victor Hugo would really love is the
fact that of course the cast Then
connects with their fans Their audience
and that actually brings some sort of
social connection I'd like to think of
something that he really would admire
well it started at the Royal Shakespeare
company and the uh the first performance
was five hours long and so they had to
condense this amazing story into three
hours
and in fact they they cut out a lot of
fantastic things they should be there
should be another show lame is the
outcuts of whatever you call it
um so the Royal Shakespeare company we
did it there for eight weeks and we had
no idea it was going to transfer to the
west end it's back to its roots the
Barbican theater where it started two
and a half decades ago to some bad
reviews and was just about to go to the
West End of course we were a bit
depressed having seen such a fantastic
reception the night before and so I
thought I'll get rid of all the bad news
at once and ring through the box office
and it took me several days and that was
where the story came from and they said
how did you get through we've taken
we've had 5 000 calls it's a record at
the barbecue I mean I knew it was going
to be a big hit years ago but I didn't
know it was going to last 21 years it's
fantastic
it's overwhelming absolutely
overwhelming and I don't necessarily
know that any of us truly understand
the significance of it and ultimately
and hopefully the impact it's actually
quite fantastic though because
the piece is really about age and youth
and to think that I did it 21 years ago
when I was the youngest adult and now
people are playing my role that weren't
even born back then but it was really
interesting because
of many young people who probably have
never seen a musical ever you know
coming in tonight and could be
completely enthralled I mean you could
hear a pin drop through the story you
know and they did and they just reacted
the show and the fact that he was
incredibly good at it as was Camilla you
know on their baptism fire tonight but
um I was really very happy oh it is nice
being back on stage um I was garage when
I was in last back in 2003 and about
seven years later I've come back to Clay
Mary's it's been a dream of mine for a
long time and to see it coming true is
an amazing thing Nick's done a couple of
shows on Broadway uh uh I think he was
in Beauty and the Beast but
um the first time I met Nick was when he
was the last gavrosh which is the little
kid in in Les Miserables on Broadway
when I closed the show the first time
after 18 years and he did the last nine
months of the Run
and I was reminded by his father
um that at the after show party I'd gone
up to him and I obviously had a few
drinks because I didn't remember
um saying you know to Nick you know you
are really terrific and I hope when
you're older you'll come back and see us
for Marius well even though I didn't
remember it he did and um I'm out of the
blue I mean I'd heard that he was
interested in going to the theater so
through another way I actually
approached him and then I spoke to his
father and he said no this is something
they would really like to try and make
happen and um
it's a great credit to the family that
they have moved Heaven and Earth to
allow him to come and be here and he's
having a great time you know I actually
wasn't as nervous as I thought it would
be um I don't think I was nervous at all
I think that I uh it's really
comfortable and
um
just happy to be on that stage and and
really trying to
become the character well what's
interesting is that he's actually got a
very mature voice for somebody who's
still 17 you know he's not quite 18 yet
and yet the voice sounds much older than
you'd expect and he's also got I mean a
tremendous Focus all the way through
rehearsals and when I first met him I
mean he really really knows what to go
after
um and he's and he just does it with no
problem great ease and the whole cast
adore him the crowd was great tonight
so incredible to be back on on the
Layman stage obviously a bit of a
different role this time but still that
same energy and that same excitement
tickets concert sold out in two and a
half hours they'll have 17 different
versions of the main character valjeon
to choose from and the comic relief of
Alan Armstrong and Jenny Galloway how
many thousands of people
about 5 000 people
no no no
I think once you see all the people and
know that everybody's rooting for you
and know that there is not a hostile
soul and the Stalls or in the orc or
anywhere it's just going to be fun you
know here and there I'm picking up the
accent I sing with one now in the show
which is kind of funny but it's very
very interesting to be here and pick up
the lingo along the way and make some
new friends as well which has been great
and I'm really enjoying my stay that you
can come and see the show here in the
morning at 10 o'clock they can go to the
matinee at the queens and then the
following day turn up with the other
thousands and tens of thousands of
people
um at the O2 for that extraordinary
concept which now has a cast of over
500. recently they've started doing
celebrity casting
in Les Mis in London and we've been
lucky enough to see possibly some of our
better grades that the what I call the
greats that are going to come forward in
the next 10 years
um the Lancashire tenor Alfie Bo has
undertaken not just one but three stints
in them is and claims it's his very
favorite role I've done the Les
Miserables I'm going to go back into Les
Miserables next this year in June to do
a six-month run
um
but
I'm wanting to really
break the genres a little bit you know
um people call it crossover people call
it all sorts of things but I I want to
just break the genre and cross over to a
new audience not to not the repertoire
so much or or sing different repertoire
but make it make sure it's legitimate
for my voice you know yeah that I'm that
I'm legitimate enough to sing it you
know
um and still sing it in the same quality
in the same standard that I would an
operatic car in a way the comedian Matt
Lucas is possibly better known uh for
shows like Little Britain and come fly
with me and he virtually begged The
Producers uh Cameron mcintosh's company
for a part in the musical which of
course did nothing to Dent the box
office it shot it through the roof and
it was like a new injection if you like
of Vitality and once again of course
making it one of the biggest take
musicals of all time
um Cameron himself said that well he's
had many many hits he never thought that
he would be known as the man who brought
Les Mis to the British and Broadway
public but how lucky we are that he took
that once
I mean I was very lucky because they
took me to Broadway as well and every
sort of musical performer wants to go to
Broadway so my dream came true when I
was 21 which is amazing
um
and also my daughter Eliza also played
Gazette at some point and I went back
into the show and I played the same role
eponine with her so
um it's emotional for me it's like like
it's my whole life I mean
I I think I have to be honest you know
it's the best role I've ever played and
it did you know it gave me an incredible
um well people still know me today from
it and the album is still selling that I
made 21 years ago so you know I for me
it's in the heart
it's really personal for me
now amongst many of the awards at Les
Miserables has picked up
this to me would be the biggest
compliment in 2004 Her Majesty the queen
asked the cast and everyone connected to
the show to Stage a very special version
at Windsor Castle for them president
president Jack Shirak now can you
imagine how nerve-wracking that must be
first of all but apparently the queen
thought this was a great idea it was an
official visit lots of people were going
to be invited and apparently sadly
there's no record there's no recording
of this particular night I think that
this really should have been recorded
and taped because you know just to see
our Our Queen enjoined this musical and
she's already been we can tell you uh
unofficially many times to see this it's
one of her personal favorites well you
don't expect to win a Tony Award when
you're that age you've seen it on the TV
and suddenly you're you're told you're
going to be up for one and then you win
it it's just bizarre I mean
this is ridiculous I'm here with all
these stars that I've heard about and
you know it's just amazing and um
I used to sort of get oh no Wars don't
mean anything but now I look at it and
I'm quite proud
every year it picks up more and more
Awards there was a special 10th
anniversary show at the Royal Albert
Hall in a recent BBC Radio poll it was
picked out as the best musical of all
time and it's hard to imagine that you
know when he wrote it whether he would
have thought that his celebrity would
have carried on I think Victor Hugo
would have thought he would have been
known in his time but his name is now
plastered across the world it's been
seen in over 30 countries it ran for
over 10 years on Broadway you know when
you think about it in those terms you
know it is something of a phenomenon I'm
just about to start on the film where
where we're now working on somebody is
working on the screenplay and I'm doing
it with working title which is you know
the Great British company that's one of
our best film company and uh I'm really
looking forward to finally getting Les
Miserables out on the big screen
Les Miserables of course is now a new
Smash Hit Mega Movie uh looking at all
sorts of gold dust from Baptist to
Globes to Oscars but it's not the first
time they're already 10 silent versions
made of this particular story there's
been a radio version there's been a
television version with Anthony Perkins
no list which was kind of warmly
received
[Music]
um
it's one of those stories that time and
time again people re-look at and think
they can retell but nobody really could
have even predicted or had the slightest
hint that the stage and Broadway version
the West engineers in a Broadway version
would be so phenomenal and of course you
know when people said first of all when
it opened in London how could you
possibly think you're gonna have a smash
eight with a title which is basically
all about being miserable Les Miserables
how wrong they were
the film will actually use the music the
wonderful music from the show but tell
the story in cinematic terms I mean what
we have here is a wonderfully a
wonderful theatrical version but you
know the cinema we will reinvent it yet
again
to tell it for the cinema what was
fantastic on this was the chance to
reunite the original creative team that
that created the musical um so you know
I wanted to create a new song for the
film that talked to that was inspired by
the novel uh which talks about the
extraordinary epiphany of what Joba Jean
has where he when he feels this
incredible love uh for this this child
that's come into his life and so I asked
Lord Michelle Schoenberg and Alan bublil
if they could come up with a with a new
song and and I had uh and herbycrest and
The Lyricist uh you know writing a new
piece for me and that was incredibly
exciting to to to get to work with the
original composer on the music
what a pleasure to meet you cheers
what's your name
I mean the film was truly beautiful I
cried away all the way through it I
loved it so much now
um I would love to know what was your
first experience
I saw it here in London but I didn't see
it until Cameron and Tom were already
making the movie and they talked to me
about it and so I was on my way to Italy
actually for a friend's wedding and so I
stopped in to see it we had a couple of
meetings about what was the biggest
challenge going into the park
well I think the challenges actually
unfolded as we went along you know it
wasn't quite clear
how challenging it was going to be at
the beginning because it's very easy to
say oh and by the way you're going to
sing every take but then the actual
reality of doing that and the discipline
that has to come into your life to keep
yourself available every day and your
voice available you know and Tom as a
director is is greedy you know he'll
shoot and he'll shoot and he'll shoot
and you know and every take we did was
the full length of the song as well so
yeah I mean you know ultimately though
this was a incredibly enjoyable
experience I grew up with the my mom
performing uh in the show in the first
national tour she understoodiedfontine
so actually one of my first memories of
seeing the show is seeing my mother play
the part that I play in the film I saw
it when I was beginning to think about
making the film and I saw it four or
five times and what was extraordinary is
after the second time the Melodies were
just in my head and that was it I mean a
lot of the last year and a half they've
just been going round and round and
round I mean they're extraordinarily
addictive
Allen
a year ago she was performing on stage
at school she's just so gorgeous it was
her first movie she has no idea how
brilliant she is she's just so natural
it may be a lot for a 10 year old to
take in but Isabelle looks set to walk
many more red carpets in the future we
did everything in one take at Tom Tom
left a few of the of the um the songs
especially the solos kind of in in one
one long continuous taker I've did very
very few Cuts in it but what he did was
he filmed most of everything from a
multi-camera approach which meant that
you could do a whole take knowing that
the entire performance was captured
because it would have been very hard I
think especially with the singing being
live to go from one take to another like
an hour can change your voice you know
it's the time of day the barometer
there's so many factors so Tom needed to
be able to capture all of the
performances live in order to to edit in
a way that wouldn't become distracting I
didn't want to make the film if I didn't
have my
and and Hugh came in and made me realize
that uh I could make this film I mean
because my shortness was one person I
mean who else can sing at that level act
in such an extraordinary way as a
Bonafide film star in the old sense
could carry a film has the requisite
strength to play a famously strong man
but also has the the grace and kind of
uh spiritual gentleness
um that the character needs it's Hugh
Jackman Tom Hooper Thursday rehearsal
said I need you actually before then he
said I need you unrecognizable he said
if people recognize you I want them to
think you're sick in real life so uh I
did my best he went he went on a really
hardcore journey to try to physically
capture what it'd be like to be a
convict of 20 years standing he lost 30
pounds of weight uh you know we shaved
his head I mean we talked a lot about
shaving sort of cutting Annie's Hair but
Hugh Jackman's head was shaved very
brutally and and and then in the opening
scene I mean this is where he's kind of
quite eccentric he he went on a 36-hour
water fast which means no water for 36
hours and and then was willing to stand
up to his chest in seawater putting a
massive ship in on a rope so that his
skin kind of went back against his
cheeks and you know a lot of people
don't recognize in the opening scene I
mean he's he's so kind of uh broken
looking by this thing I mean and and
then and then he and then when his
character kind of flourishes you then
put on weight and changed again and I
mean like his commitment to this was was
was total yeah my trainer on this movie
Incredible guy David Kingsbury
um has at one point in his life was a
bodybuilder and he knew of this water
restriction thing which is what
bodybuilders did before a show and you
can lose up to 10 pounds of body weight
and right off the surface do not do this
at home
trust me and so it really sinks in your
chair I was already quite skinny but it
makes it quite drastic your eyes get
sunken I look like hell basically and
trust me the headache after about 20
hours is something I don't want to
repeat
Stratford doing uh
and I received a phone call from my
agent telling me that I would be playing
the eponymous hero tonight of the house
just like the singing all the tears were
done live
um they were they weren't
mine I mean I was definitely in a
fragile place that day because my hair
was going to be gone but but no I really
did try to kind of stay with fontine and
if Victor Hugo has this wonderful
passage in the book where he talks about
pontine really didn't want to cut her
hair and how she receives a letter from
the dinardia saying that because that
doesn't have a skirt for winter she's
going to be cold and she sat there
crumbling the letter in her hand for an
entire day and then just like around
Sunset goes down to the wig maker and
says take it how much for it he said 10
francs and she says cut it off then and
she sat there and trying to be stoic
thinking I'm clothing my hair with I'm
clothing my child with my hair and I
just kind of tried to bring some of that
Grace into it not just have it all be
about me
foreign
any physical transformation that you
undergo is obviously going to be
difficult but I couldn't take it too
seriously because it was my idea to lose
my hair and it was my idea to go to the
extreme physical place that I did for
this and I did it for my job and a lot
of people don't have a choice about it a
lot of people get sick and they lose
weight they get sick and they have to
lose their hair Tom Hoover who's not a
musical theater director before he went
to see the show and really fell in love
with it and he said how do I
recreate that feeling that you get in
the theater and so he wanted to sing
live and what he does actually is
enhance the theatrical experience for
example Anne Hathaway her song I Dreamed
a Dream which of course everybody feels
they know is a single shot without
cutting for three minutes of her in
closer it's one of the great
performances ever given and I think
and you never cut away from it so it's
like being in the theater but the best
seat you you couldn't even get that seat
in the theater it's like sitting in her
lap and listening to it you know and
there wasn't anything about this job
that wasn't daunting I mean we were all
just kind of this mixture of of anxiety
and gratitude and and excitement and
nerves and
um but you know and then of course you
show up on set and you're just like
because we'd all been kind of working in
our own lives on the music and you show
up and you hear Hugh Jackman and of
course we kind of all knew that you
could sing but not like this and then
Eddie Redmayne with the most gorgeous
voice just coming out of nowhere
so I mean so it was it was exciting to
work with everybody here what they were
doing but I think you know hearing how
how talented everyone else was kind of
pushed us all on to me on at least
in total three on tape three in person
two flights to London
[Music]
you know 60 million people have seen it
around the world londoners taken it to
their hearts in the very beginning I
wanted to uh
protect what it is people love about it
and somehow take that and intensify it
on the big screen and I think it's how
it makes people feel and how people you
go back and back to re-experience these
strong emotions I wanted to make the
emotions they feel even more intense on
the big screen I don't think
hard or easy
it's my job
so you know it's not it's not like it
all kind of a feeling comes to you in
one great moment you're like oh
quite good at this or oh I'm terrible at
this it's you're so far removed from it
and at that point I've done so much
preparation that I was so into it it
wasn't really about
performing it was more about just
honoring what I had learned in the
research that I had done and just trying
to open myself wide enough to let all
that come out
um really amazing to to
be up there is so cool
well Jean version for actors it's a bit
like a hamlet or something it it is the
kind of role you dream of playing and
also secretly terrified of blame because
it requires everything of you and with
Jean Valjean emotionally physically and
vocally every day it requires that
usually all at the same time so it was
an incredible opportunity and I'm just
so lucky to have been working with Tom
Hooper and these other great actors you
know you know I used to go to the Empire
Leicester Square and the odinessa square
as a kid uh and and dream of one day
having a film maybe in those Cinemas I
remember the ritualist as I left I'd
always turn back and watch the end
credits roll and make a kind of
commitment to myself to try to get a
film on one of those screens and have
both screens of the premiere last night
with 3 000 people was a kind of great I
don't know homecoming for me as a London
attempt to to have that opportunity you
know he would have everyone over when we
were in London and it was great because
he had a very very great you know State
over there and uh it was a lot a lot of
fun and it was a lot it was nice after
long weeks for everyone to come together
and do that and and he's just a great
guy
[Music]
at the beginning it's a very
embarrassing thing to actually sing to
people it's very exposing thing to be
like yeah you know we're on set and so
when you get you were allowed to get so
relaxed around each other and learned
and you didn't feel awkward
there have been subsequently some wild
singing parties we were down in a pub in
in New York the other day and Russell
and Russell's mate with a guitar and we
were all singing singing songs it's uh
it's I've never quite got over the fear
factor of it but it is quite
entertaining do you know what I feel so
proud to be a part of this I it was so
odd last night we had the premiere and
we ended up driving back to it there was
a party afterwards and we sort of drove
through Leicester Square and up shafts
we haven't even passed where Lamers is
on and there in the Palace Theater where
it used to play I have so many memories
as a kid of walking up and down those it
was wanting to you know maybe be an
actor but but it never was in my wildest
dreams I get to be a part of it so yeah
I feel very privileged I Dreamed a Dream
yeah that was it was uh it may not have
been the first plus since you see
Russell loves a sing-along uh and if you
ever get invited to his place for a
party lucrative yeah right after you do
David Letterman uh then make sure you
take a song because he gets every
everyone scene
yeah but it was a great way to let off
steam I mean we were all you were not
allowed to sing any of your songs from
your uh repertoire and the musical that
was the Only Rule it's you know it's
easy to see why ebony loves Marius when
he when he looks like Eddie Redmayne you
know but then equally it's easy to see
why he loves because uh when it's Amanda
Seyfried to be fair
yeah no there was a lot but the thing
about this film
it's an embarrassing minute but we're
all such sort of aggressive Les Mis fans
that it's the first film I've seen when
people would come in to set on their
days off to kind of see how everyone was
doing there's no no one to miss out so
yeah there was we were all very
supportive well
you know
when you I've always admired Hugh
Jackman I've always respected his career
and his work I think he's just got a
fantastic range in what he does he's a I
just think the world of him
professionally and so then you know I
was thinking well no you meet someone
who's almost like an idol and you think
well they're never going to match that
expectation well here's the thing with
Hugh Jackman him didn't match it he
raised it I just didn't think somebody
could be so cool with all the success
he's had to be this the most
level-headed person he is so calm on set
he's like hi it's lovely and then it's
like action and this like character
bursts out of his soul and it's like wow
and for me that's inspiring at the
beginning of my career to meet somebody
like that who's got that perfect balance
I look at you know he's inspiring to me
definitely
um I spent the most time with
Eddie yeah I think yes
and who did you bond with the most what
do you say
um
so I guess Eddie I guess about no
I don't know yeah I guess Eddie for the
most part I wanted with Eddie and
Samantha
um
but we all kind of had I mean we we all
had scenes together
and throughout rehearsal we were able to
kind of get to know each other and and
bond
through like the the terror of singing
live and also the fact that we were all
major major Lamaze fans and the fact
that we all worked like our asses off to
get the roles
so but I guess I spent the most time
with Eddie and Samantha and um
it was a nice little group
I think it was it was just the
difference in in how you convey this
emotion I think in a theater you're
projecting to 2000 seats and
everything's heightened because there's
no point having a little private Moment
On Stage you need people to connect with
that story and and to sort of feel feel
what your character's feeling
and and on screen the camera's so close
to you that you feel you know it's so
intimate you can be more truthful and
that realism is amazing but then you
can't beat that live Buzz of theater so
what I feel is excited about this this
project it's only from an acting point
of view is combining those two together
so it's kind of that utter realism of
film but with that kind of live buzz you
get in theater it's combining the two to
create something that feels unique
um I have sing just had to sing I was
completely completely
out of my comfort zone and you know very
very insecure about my voice I
definitely wish I'd had more time to
prepare this soprano
um technique but you know I
I did my best and I feel like you know
this is the kind of it's just a unique
experience and and I'm not it's not
gonna the opportunity is not gonna come
around very often so I
well I didn't get a call
that was the first step basically I was
performing as Nancy and Oliver on stage
and Cameron McIntosh the producer walked
on and announced to a live audience
yeah but I was gonna be playing eponine
Lewis that was my face right there that
was my reaction
and it's on YouTube I I've watched it
since because I can't remember it I just
remember hearing epony I remember my
heart nearly falling out of my chest and
going because I've never worn anything
more I never wanted this it's been a
part well for four years it's a
character that I feel so passionate
about and oh gosh and to get that news
in that way it that was my reaction
right there you did a really good
impression of me it was like my inner
you know
teenager who grew up with Ali G and you
know all those things was I had I was
properly Starstruck by by Sasha and he
arrived on set to the point that he and
Helena Bonham Carter arrived at a point
in which we've been going to this
rigorous quite sort of intense process
forever
and um and they arrived in this sort of
lightness arrived that made me um very
happy it was just that was a bit of a
sort of
lifetime aspiration was to I never
thought I'd get the opportunity to work
with him but it was pretty wonderful to
do I think
I think although as a world I knew
nothing about at least I can kind of I
knew this girl I knew this this this
piece I knew I felt so passionately
about it so to be that was a one
comforting thing I think about entering
I want to to work with these actors that
I'd you know admired for years people
like you Jackman you know and it's Eddie
Redman I knew had been cast as Marius
and when I was auditioning for eponine
there was posters everywhere with my
work with Marilyn and I was like
remember just being like positive
thinking he could be my Marius and
working with people like that that was
such a highlight I was lucky enough to
attend many of these Gala Knights of Les
Mis and they've always been magical
um you know any Musical that celebrates
a particular Milestone is always sort of
like one of those moments where you
think it's been going so long can you
really inject something into that and it
does have that magical touch I think
what's also interesting is the fact that
as somebody who's seen it as I say quite
a few times now you go along and each
time there's always something that you
don't quite remember from the first time
or the second time and you do come away
it's what they call one of those
musicals it's what they call a memorable
musical not just because of the story
but particularly with the songs you do
go out and Days Later you've got this
fantastic melody in your head and you're
thinking to yourself what is that what
is that because with a lot of songs from
musicals you don't always know the title
but you only have to hear the you know
the sort of the words of on my own and
it strikes a chords to any generation
and I do kind of think that that's why
it's been covered by so many people so
many people resonate with the lyrics and
the Beautiful Melody of many of the
songs from uh the score of Les Mis and I
think it will go on for many many years
in people's minds
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]